- [Mark] So, what are your names?
- Ozzy.
- [Kaitlin] And Kaitlin.
- [Mark] Kaitlin.
And where are you guys from?
- [Kaitlin] Chicago, Illinois.
- [Mark] Chicago, I see.
How long you guys been out here?
- [Ozzy] Maybe two and a half years.
- [Mark] Two and a half years in LA,
and then how long on Skid Row?
Or close to here.
- No in LA for two and a half years,
in Skid Row we've probably been
a good seven months, right?
- [Kaitlin] Yeah, sixish months probably.
- Yeah, pardon my-
- Not too long,
we used to stay in MacArthur Park,
not much better.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Kind of the same scene.
- Not much worse. (laughs)
- Yeah (laughs)
- [Mark] Is it worse?
- I said not much worse.
- [Mark] Not much worse, right.
- It's like the same,
not...there's more gang
activity over there
- [Mark] Yeah
- Yeah, here's less incorporated
- [Mark] And you guys are on the street?
- Yes.
- [Mark] How long you been
in the cold on the street?
- Me personally, just this whole time,
him, like forever.
- A good decade on and off
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah, I've gotten bunch of apartments,
and you know I really
taken my time to enjoy
and suck the juice out of like, you know,
conditioned living,
you know what I mean,
in a box with an air conditioner and stuff
and then I get hungry
for the road ya know,
I'm before all other things a traveler,
I'm not really a...
I don't feel like sticking to
one spot is really my style,
we've just kinda got shackled
by a few things kinda here
and also
it's kind of comfortable in a way.
- LA got us a little bit stuck.
- Yeah.
- We were supposed to ride freight trains
and be on this romantic
adventure and uh...
- The qualms of like addiction
and what not, you know.
- [Mark] What's your drug of choice?
- [Ozzy And Katilin] Heroin
- [Mark] Heroin? Both you guys?
- [Ozzy And Katilin] Yeah
- [Mark] Yeah, heroin's a bad one.
- [Ozzy] Yeah
- [Kaitlin] Yeah, now its
a just straight fentanyl.
We don't even bother with
the heroin part anymore.
We just smoke fentanyl.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- [Kaitlin] Yeah.
- [Ozzy] It's crazy-
[Kaitlin] -it's horrible.
- [Ozzy] It's crazy cuz
it's more involving,
and sucks more out of you
than even intravenous use.
You just smoke it and...
- [Kaitlin] It's like, you know,
you see crack heads on the street
and you think oh crack's like probably,
oh those people are the worst people.
Fentanyl makes you a worse crack head
than crack does I think.
(Mark murmurs)
If that makes sense.
- [Ozzy] I can't say it's not without
its beautiful parts though,
you know what I mean.
- [Mark] What are the upsides of-
- [Ozzy] I mean, just the
time that I spend with her,
and little magic moments
you have you know,
that kinda completely transport
us out of this you know.
It's still like
kind of like
an intoxicating little fairy
tale of it's own, you know.
And just like exploring her...
- [Mark] How old are you guys?
- [Ozzy] I'm 28, 29. 30!
- [Mark] You're 30?
- [Ozzy] Yeah.
- [Kaitlin] I just turned 24.
- [Mark] 24?
Where would you guys like to
see yourselves in five years?
- [Ozzy] Almost exactly where
I was like three years ago,
four years ago.
I had a really cool apartment
with really good people,
and stuff like that.
And I kinda just, I got a
tiny smudge of legal trouble,
like a smudge seriously, and...
- [Mark] What kind of trouble?
- Just, I just had um...
- We sold LSD in Chicago,
which holds an eight year sentence.
- Yeah, but I could have beat all that,
I really just had a little
drug charge that snowballed,
and I just had to do drug classes for it,
I could never complete them,
so I kept getting locked up for it,
it was like a yo-yo process.
Knowing now what I,
if I knew then what I know now,
I probably would just face the music
- Yeah, like go to jail
- It seems like...
- or take prison time or whatever
(sirens in the background)
but he kept choosing probation, and...
- It'd be like 60 days
as opposed to you know...
- That's like hard to complete
all of their hoops they want
you to jump through, you know.
- Yeah.
I thought, oh, I can't
leave her alone for 60 days,
and now its kinda like it's own...
- I have literally been
left alone for 60 days.
- [Mark] What age were you
when you guys did drugs
for the first time?
- Like, officially I'd say 16.
- [Mark] And what drug was that?
- LSD, yeah LSD.
And then I also did,
I mean I tried heroin
when I was 16 as well.
- [Mark] Oh, you did?
- Yeah, kinda weird I don't know.
- I, I started with the
gateway drug, weed. (laughs)
- Yeah I didn't try weed
until I was way older
- Weed and alcohol, but
like that was when I was 15,
and I didn't do any hardcore drugs until
I basically met you, probably.
- Makes sense.
- It's not your fault,
its just the crew we
were hanging out with was
- Yeah that didn't stop-
- already addicts
- I cried for three months,
I was like can we please
just smoke weed today guys?
And they were already completely in the
what's it called?
- Throes?
- Yeah.
- Throes of like,
- Addiction?
- Habitual use, yeah.
- I didn't start daily use
either until we started dating.
But yeah, it just snowballs
so quickly, like I said.
- [Mark] Tell me about your
childhood, your family.
- Um, I came into the country at age 3,
my father
was a reporter in
El Salvador. Correspondence work
for Time Magazine and stuff,
covering the war out there.
He's named after Oscar Romero,
the archbishop of El Salvador
at the time, he was assassinated,
he was like a close friend
of my family's and stuff. And
yeah I don't know, and then
my mom, like, all of our
assets were seized by the
Salvadorian government,
we fled to Mexico, fled
to this country, my mom
worked to build a life for us
and when I was like, eleven,
she kind of, you know,
had everything put together,
and we just continued life,
me and my brother, her, my brother, and I,
and, it was pretty
perfect, I'm not gonna lie.
It worked, it was good, a
really loving mother, and yeah.
How about you?
- Well, my mom had me out of
wedlock, and when I was three,
three or four, she married my step-dad,
and when I was like, ten-ish,
my mom moved to Chicago, she got pregnant
with twins, my little brother
and sister. They're like,
my step-siblings, but really
they're just my siblings.
And my step-dad's really just my dad.
My step-dad's kind of
an asshole, he never drank or anything,
he just had like, habitual
verbal abuse problems, mostly.
It became physical when
I was like, eleven.
- [Mark] With you?
- Yeah, uh, and that, you know,
like I grew up in a really,
really nice community on
the North Shore of Chicago,
and that just sort of threw
me into a sort of rebellious
phase I guess?
And so I started hanging out with
the wrong crowd, so to speak,
the Kids Without Dads club.
(laughing)
- The Lost Boys.
- Yeah, stuff like that.
I don't know. I had a
really good family too.
I didn't come from anything
dirt poor, or anything like
super bad.
- [Mark] No like, sexual
abuse or anything like that?
- No.
I think, I don't know,
I'm not really sure.
- [Mark] You guys are happy
with your situation right now?
- Not at all, not at all.
We want to quit every day,
we get into fights over it all the time.
He just found a rehab that,
Medicali doesn't pay for
medical, like, withdrawal.
- Medical detoxing.
- Yeah, we need a medical
detox. That's just a fact.
- We've been going through
detoxes and rehabs,
not going through them
physically but just like,
calling, on the internet.
- I've physically, I've
physically gone through
like, one and a half.
- No, no, but did you-
- No, but in Chicago-
- But in Chicago I had
gone into a couple rehabs.
But that was when I was
17 man, super indifferent
about the results, you know.
- [Mark] You see what the
future is down the road
for this, right?
- Yeah.
- Uh, it's right outside.
- [Mark] Look around,
it's not a pretty picture.
- Well I mean I knew when I
watched Requiem for a Dream,
what I was kind of, in
a sense, signing up for,
but now there's a big part
of me that, ah, is growing
and growing and kind
of trying to take back
the steering wheel of my
life, build something,
build a nest for us and whatnot.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, good luck with that.
- Appreciate it.
- [Mark] Thank you so
much for talking with me.
- Absolutely.
You're easy to talk to.
- [Mark] I'll give you a
ride back to your place.
- All right
- Thank you